for over 40 years this country has been
operating in a state of emergency people
live under the shadow of violent power
struggles of death and destruction the
International Security Assistance Force
has been here since 2001 but it hasn't
been able to dispel the threat of the
Taliban we've arranged to meet Wahid
mazda in the 90s he was a foreign
affairs adviser to the short-lived
taliban government he's a political
analyst known as a taliban diplomat we
hope the new regime make a piece of
security Afghanistan Afghanistan people
words for peace and security they can
suffer everything but the bad situation
Afghanistan is security this problem
should be should be earned and should be
finished and we hope the new government
make this and it's impossible without
talking a negotiation Vitaly the
tensions are emphasized by deep
rivalries between tribal and ethnic
groups the outcome of the presidential
election still isn't known opposition
politician Abdullah Abdullah is seen as
the favorite he's openly anti-taliban if
he wins how will he handle ly Islamists
to keep the door open for the talks with
the Taliban is yes finding an agreement
it will not take one side it will take
two sides so Jada when I first serious
efforts pursuing the negotiations with
the Taliban from our part will continue
all I can say that the desire of the
Afghan nation for having peace durable
in just peace is that in the state and
the leadership will have to pursue that
rush of the nation in a very genuine in
serious man
in the Afghan capital Kabul at least the
situation seems to be improving streets
and markets are bustling with people
there's a sense of relative safety it's
safer at least than the southern and
eastern provinces the number of small
industries like this foundry on the
outskirts of the city is increasing
their homegrown international investment
is still very rare after the election
result is announced the new president
will take up office in August his key
responsibility then we'll be finding the
way to make a new start after all our
talks your Afghanistan it is quite clear
that even a new government will have
tremendous prop problems if they do not
integrate the Taliban at least the
political wing of the Taliban and to the
priests peace process if they don't if
they ignore the insurgents it might
happen that they simply sit back and
relax until the end of 2016 until the
international troops out and then
struggle for power again